HASMIG SAMURKASHIAN:
Hello, everybody.
Welcome.
My name is Hasmig Samurkashian.
Welcome to "Managing
Change in an SAP World."
I'm going to cover for you
some of the key capabilities
that Google Cloud has to
offer for SAP customers
to help mitigate the vast
change in these environments.
And I'm also going to share with
you some examples of customers
who have deployed their
SAP environments on Google
Cloud and the
results that they're
seeing with these deployments.
So from the perspective of
challenges for SAP customers,
times change.
There's different
times, different year.
But there's a lot of
consistency in the challenges
that these customers see.
The primary one, of course,
is business continuity
for these mission-critical
environments.
They got to stay up and running.
They got to stay up and running
to support the business.
But in parallel, businesses
are demanding more, certainly.
There's economic value that
has to be driven, agility,
keeping up with
the pace of change,
keeping up with the
needs of the business,
and then innovation--
certainly beyond just
the tiny, incremental pieces of
innovation, innovation that's
really going to
drive improvements.
So Google Cloud, then, for SAP
customers has so much to offer.
I'm going to hit the
highlights here and then
go into some more detail
later in the presentation.
So starting with robust
security and a robust network,
that's the
underpinning, the ground
for any cloud deployment.
Added to it with
smart infrastructure,
things like agility, the high
availability, the disaster
recovery--
critical, again, for
SAP environments.
And then the capabilities of
a digital business platform,
a true digital platform around
analytics and machine learning
and artificial intelligence.
And then lastly, Google Cloud's
commitment to your success--
this is not an easy
adventure, not an easy project
to move a mission-critical
environment like SAP
to the cloud.
And we have a lot
of things in place
to help you mitigate risk
and help you to get there.
So jumping into the
network and security,
I just want to start by
saying that, as a baseline,
Google Cloud is battle
tested from the get
go for performance, for
reliability, for security.
It is already running
the same environment,
delivering applications at
planet-scale, applications
that you know, many
that you probably
use, like G Suite
and Maps and YouTube
and Search and
Android and others,
where the environment
is delivering
planet-scale, robust, secure
infrastructure already
for these billions of users
that are using these key Google
applications every day.
So our security
schema or environment
really is around defense
at depth and at scale.
And that means that every
element of the architecture
has security baked
in, essentially.
And we build security
through progressive layers.
Mostly, we build
everything ourselves.
We buy very, very little
hardware in the end.
Servers, for example, we're the
second or third largest server
manufacturer in the world.
And we're the only
customer of our servers.
Our data centers, we build
them from the ground up.
And boards, for example, they
have custom chips on board
that allow them to be
constantly monitoring, looking
for intrusions, looking for
possible changes or problem
areas.
So every layer of
the environment
has security built in.
Another key component of
security is data encryption.
And this is a unique Google
Cloud feature in the sense
that encryption is done by
default for data and packets
in transit and at rest.
And there's nothing you need to
do to take advantage of that.
That's by default.
So we don't see your data.
We don't reuse drives.
If a customer were
to move on, we
would destroy a
physical hard drive.
We would never reuse
a physical hard drive.
When it comes to the keys
for your environment,
you have complete
control of the keys.
You keep your own
keys if you want to.
We can hold your keys for you
if you want us to do that.
So you are in control of
those critical security
elements of your environment.
From a network
perspective, there's
lots of-- probably
lots of pictures
that look just like
this one, with the globe
and dots and lines and wires.
But the difference with
Google Cloud's network
is a couple of points.
First of all, it's ours.
We built it.
We own it.
All the blue lines, those
undersea cables, they're ours.
We own them.
We own the ships
and the submarines
that maintain and manage
those cables, that
have put those cables
under the ocean floor.
So we have full control
over the network.
And that's pretty
important, because when
we send your data from
one region to another,
we do not traverse
the public network.
So this is both a security
enhancement for you
as well as a
performance enhancement.
It gives you the lowest
latency possible for your SAP
applications.
And the network does matter.
The network matters
tremendously for securities.
And the top here, there's
a typical schema going on,
what we call the hot
potato syndrome, where
basically one of your
data packets gets
tossed around, essentially,
from one network to another
on its way to its
final destination.
In Google Cloud,
that never happens.
Essentially, again,
we send your data
from one point to another,
one region to another
without traversing
the public networks.
So big advantages
for SAP customers.
Take, again, HADR,
for example, where
you can host your
high-availability systems
in different
locations in a region
and ensure synchronous
updates that
are sub-millisecond, extremely
fast, low-latency updates.
For DR, for disaster
recovery, we
can provision DR sites
that are milliseconds away.
So we'll come back to
HA and DR and talk more
about that, as critical as
it is for SAP customers.
So moving on now to
smart infrastructure--
so augmenting the
baseline of security,
the baseline of the
network with capabilities
like agility and more
HA and DR capabilities.
So the base here for our
Google Cloud SAP infrastructure
is a virtualized environment.
We made the decision three
years back or so when
we decided to host SAP
environments that we would
be making an investment
in virtual machines,
and very large virtual
machines for SAP systems.
And that's two advantages
that it offers customers.
One is that you don't have
to get it right in sizing.
Even though you do, you run
the tools and the scenarios
and you choose the size of
your initial environment,
it's hard to get it right.
But you don't have
to on Google Cloud,
because once you get here, you
can quickly adjust and adjust
without penalty.
And then go forward, you
can resize without penalty,
whether changing
times, changing things
going on in the market
and the environment.
You can adjust and
resize your environment
with what the business demands.
Or maybe on the
weekends or at night,
you want to turn stuff
off, like your dev or test
or non-production environments.
That's available to you, too,
to save money, save money
in compute instances.
So global provisioning in
minutes, large VMs that
are in production in
customer environments,
and more-- and more investment
coming in this area in future.
So a key capability that
we are able to offer
in the high-availability
space around planned downtime
is live migration.
And this is another
thing that we're
able to offer because of
our VM-based environment.
And essentially, what
this is is it's--
live migration keeps
virtual machine instances
up and running through
planned host system events,
like a hypervisor
update, like a like
a patch, a basic hardware
or hardware patch.
And this is big
for SAP customers,
when some can't even afford to
take a system down for an hour,
a month, because that lost
downtime is something that they
simply cannot afford.
But the way it
works, essentially,
is you take your
productive live--
your productive environment
and move it to another VM,
keep running, certainly
no big reboots required.
And update the
original environment.
Patch and update as needed.
And then you roll back when
the update is completed.
So live migrating, live
instances without reboots,
performing infrastructure
updates without disruption--
and then we, too,
Google Cloud, take
advantage of this
capability to make sure
that your environment
is always up to date.
We're not trading off
downtime and updates.
We're keeping it
updated all the time.
And we'll never
send you an email
saying the environment's going
to go down on Sunday afternoon.
You need to be prepared,
because we don't take down
our environment.
And you don't need to,
either, for doing these types
of maintenance updates.
All right, so moving
on more around
availability, HA and DR--
so this is so important for
SAP customers to get right.
Again, you architect it rarely.
But when you have to use it,
it really needs to be right.
Most of the environments look
like on the left of this page,
where your HA environment is
spread over multiple VPCs,
virtual private clouds.
And that's not great,
from even in good times.
It introduces additional
points of entry
from a security risk standpoint.
But then even concerning
more is if you have a failure
and you have to actually
failover to a secondary system,
it could take a lot of
time, because you've
got to inform the downstream
systems that IP addresses have
changed, et cetera.
So all your upstream-downstream
systems have to be made aware.
And this could take
hours in some cases.
In the Google Cloud
setup on the right,
it's completely different.
Your HA can be configured
within the same VPC.
So lets say, in the
event of a failed system,
you failover to a secondary,
which was already up
and running to begin with.
You failover to your secondary.
And basically, it's
synchronously updated.
And you're back up and running.
You're failed over
within seconds,
without impacting
upstream-downstream
applications.
There's none of
that IP remapping
that has to take place.
You don't have to send resets.
There's no DNS table updates.
It's business continuity.
It's business
continuity maintained
for a mission-critical
environment.
So I want to share with you
all here not just me talking,
but from one of our customers,
Cardinal Health, one
of the largest pharmaceutical
distributors in the United
States.
And they've been running
live SAP HANA on Google Cloud
for about nine months or so.
And I'd like you to take a
listen to their experiences
running SAP on Google Cloud.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END PLAYBACK]
All right, so moving on to
the digital business platform,
analytics capabilities,
machine learning--
some of these real game-changing
type of technologies
for your SAP environment.
They're easier than you think,
actually, to get on board with
and deploy.
So how does Google Cloud really
innovate for SAP customers?
A number of areas that
I want to cover for you.
First, on the left
here is actually
containerization
with Kubernetes,
something so important for
customers, for SAP customers,
where, like it or not, for
the foreseeable future,
this is multi-cloud
and hybrid cloud.
And even if you're able to
move your SAP, your primary SAP
environment to the
cloud, you still
have to deal with
upstream-downstream
applications.
Some will be still
on-prem for a while.
Some will be hybrid.
Some will be in other clouds.
So how do you take all
of these applications
and elegantly containerize
them and move ahead
without fear of
the hybrid nature
or the multi-cloud nature
of the world we're in?
And the answer for
that is Kubernetes
for containerization,
and then Google Cloud
Anthos to help you to build,
deploy, and manage applications
in this multi-cloud,
hybrid cloud world.
There's also Apigee, which is--
really, for SAP customers, takes
care of a really key concern
in the area of innovation, where
so many customers are concerned
about integration testing.
This is like--
becomes the worry when
they want to explore
new areas of innovation.
Then when they go to test
and do integration tests,
they're worried they're
going to break something.
They're going to break
a downstream or upstream
application environment.
And with Apigee, you
don't have to worry
about that, because
essentially, it
provides a way to
extract the API layer
so that you're protected.
Your downstream
applications are protected
from this kind of testing.
So infrastructure as a
service, we've already covered.
I want to move along and
talk more about analytics
and machine learning.
So in the analytic
space, smart analytics,
critical to be using your
business data in an informed
and in a smart way.
There's a bunch of, certainly,
SAP operational data,
of course.
But most of the data, right,
is in enterprise data stores.
And they're disparate, right?
Hard to make good use out
of disparate data stores.
So this is where
BigQuery comes in, where
you can pull in your
HANA data, your SAP data,
Enterprise data,
and then even in some cases,
external data sources,
put them into this petabyte
scale data warehouse, BigQuery,
and leverage our
integration that we have,
SAP and HANA and Google
Cloud, BigQuery integration,
and really maximize the
decision-making power
that you can pull out of this
set of combined data sources.
Then there's also amazing
power with machine-learning
capabilities, and so many really
exciting use cases in the SAP
space around machine learning.
Like automating business
processes, so many
to automate there, use cases
around better understanding
your customer, sales,
and marketing use cases,
or certainly supply
chain automation as well.
And Google Cloud
offers the ability
to combine our very powerful
AI-ML toolset, along with also
some key data signals that
come from Google applications
themselves, like adding
to your operational data,
adding examples like
inventory positions,
or maybe ads data information,
or maybe competitive pricing
information, all
added together and fed
into machine learning models
for very powerful insights.
There's one example I want
to share with you here,
which is a customer
we have, AES,
who is a energy
company, actually.
And their use case for
Google Cloud machine learning
is actually they're leveraging
our AI-powered visual
inspection capability,
so specifically using
AutoML for predicting
cracks in windmill turbines.
The way it works is they've got
a set of drones that fly around
these windmill turbines all
day long during daylight hours
and take photographs
of the turbines
and send those photographs
in the thousands back.
And those photographs,
if they had
to be analyzed by
hand or by humans,
it would take forever, right,
to be looking, studying them all
and looking for inconsistencies
or cracks or issues.
But what they've done
instead is they've
leveraged Google Cloud's AutoML
Vision capability, trained
a model to very highly
accurately detect cracks
and issues with the turbines.
And they've saved
the 57,000 hours
of manual time, $10
million in cost savings
by automating this capability
with Google Cloud's
visual inspection capability.
So back to Cardinal
Health, I wanted
to show a second example, the
same team at Cardinal Health,
and how they have taken their
basic SAP on Google Cloud
environment and taken
it one step further
with their first
ever machine-learning
implementation.
It's a straightforward
implementation, but also
a pretty powerful one,
showing how it can really
save a lot of man hours
and a lot of money
for an organization.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
All right, so the
last piece here
is really about Google Cloud
being committed to your success
as an SAP customer.
And it's not lost
on us the challenge,
the concern about moving your--
moving SAP, which in many
cases, the business runs
on SP, moving it to the cloud.
So we have a number
of things that I
want to share with
you here that we
have to mitigate
the concerns here
and to support you at
this critical transition.
So back about November
of 2019, Google Cloud
introduced what we call the
Cloud Acceleration Program.
It's the first of this type
of program in the industry.
And it's a combination
of with our partners,
and you can see there on
the right of the slide
a number of our foundational
partners for the Cloud
Acceleration Program.
So it's Google Cloud with
our partners offering
a bunch of really critical
capabilities for you
as you move to the cloud,
move SAP to Google Cloud.
And some examples are migration
assessments, migration
incentives, such as Google
Cloud covering cloud migration
costs for most lift
and shift scenarios
based on a three-year
infrastructure commit.
We also will cover
you such that there'll
be no double infrastructure
costs that will cut over.
So you got your productive
environment on-prem, possibly,
still running.
You're still paying for it.
You're still funding.
But now you've got your
pre-productive environment
on the cloud while you're
working toward cutover.
We have a scenario with the
Cloud Acceleration Program
that we will eliminate
those double costs for you.
So you can get to the cloud
without that duplicative cost
scenario.
Also, piloting
analytics-- use cases,
piloting machine
learning use cases,
they're not as hard as you
might think they are, actually.
And with some of our
fantastic tech partners
here, listed here,
we can help you pilot
and play around
with, get your feet
wet in some of these critical
business innovation areas.
And then also, Google
supports safeguarding
your entire environment.
At the end of day, it's
the most important thing,
that SAP stays running and
supporting the business.
And we have Enterprise
support capabilities
that complement SAP's support
capabilities to make sure
that you are
continuously running.
So as I close here, I just
thought I would just share,
flash a subset of
our Google Cloud SAP
customers that are
trusting their critical SAP
environment to Google Cloud.
I encourage you to let us
know how we can help you.
Let us know how we can help you
get started on this journey.
Check out the resources.
There tons of resources
on our SAP Solutions page.
And thank you so
much for your time.
Thanks for joining today.